foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
look who's got a popular podcast
Marcellus Wiley the more to it podcast
Dan Patrick Podcast Network thing is
going up the charts man he's leaving
these other podcasts in the dust
congratulations there be more to it
podcast Marcellus Wiley wherever you get
your podcast also available at
danpatrick.com where do you want to
start
oh man uh one thank you Dan for the
platform opportunity to come on here
every week for the podcast our
partnership uh is going so well uh it's
therapeutic uh it's my diary and it's
just all my experiences and expressions
being laid out for the fans and so far
so great if you were on the Cowboys your
defensive lineman as a former cowboy and
your place kicker has missed
three in a row three extra points
you're going to play a role as one of
the leaders on the Cowboys
what do you do uh one I got to remind
them that those three misses are not
connected I think what happens a lot of
times with momentum uh we connect things
and therefore you go with that momentum
even if it's negative so in this moment
you know you want to stop the flow you
want him to make the nest kick so you
have to remind them you missing the
first kick wasn't because you were off
you're rather because you had a bad
morning it wasn't because of anything
you just missed a kick now you missed
the second kick it's not because you
missed the first kick and sometimes you
can spiral out of control so I will calm
them down make sure he knew that every
play was an independent play and
approach it with that mindset but if you
jump on them if you criticize them if
you make them all of a sudden start to
feel like oh my God the world is falling
on my shoulders then obviously you're
gonna go out there and miss four okay
but you're being
you're showing composure here
in the moment
and this might cost you a chance to
advance
yeah we had Tony Dungy on last time he
said he would have benched him after the
third Miss and gone for two
oh wow so that's Tony Dungy doing that
are you gonna keep your you know leap
together on the sidelines as you see Dak
Prescott didn't you know he's showing
his emotions yeah you got to think about
it look I am one of the other 52 players
and let's just say 50 of them already
giving them hell and I'm like that's not
gonna work right now because his
cheerleaders don't have pom-poms like in
between his ears his head he is down on
himself if I don't rise if I don't help
him lift himself and help him raise
himself in this moment the dude's gonna
die on the field we literally going to
see him just implode on the field so
somebody has to give the balance and act
I'm not saying I'm not dog cursing him
inside my own head but I know in that
moment brother needs a hand and he needs
a hand up so I would have extended it to
him I don't know why people were
surprised Dallas's performance because
Tampa is not good
and no running game offensive line was
spotty defense didn't step up and and
Dallas does have a lot of talent there I
you know as I've said I was betting on
Tom Brady I was not betting on Tampa Bay
and even Tom wasn't good in this
situation either
judging body language with Tom Brady
Tom Brady is where next year doing what
you know it's funny because everyone was
betting on Tampa or thinking they had a
shot because of the Mystique of Tom
Brady not not necessarily the production
or who he was in this moment just the
Mystique and that was also why people
weren't really believing that Dallas
could do it because something about the
Cowboys the Cowboys were Cowboy or
whatever that narrative is right but
then in reality it's about how well you
play and the Cowboys played well what
does Tom Brady land I tell you this he's
certainly taken a one-way flight out of
Tampa Bay he is going upstairs
exchanging all of his human capital all
of his resume all of his greatness and
the fact that he gave them a
championship in year one and saying let
me free let me go now Tom Brady's gonna
go either Miami
Las Vegas
uh and a wild card team out there that's
just going to show up and just say hey
we got to have Brady for this amount of
time it probably could it's not gonna be
San Francisco but San Francisco's
certainly going to Peak and poke around
with this situation but we're Purdy the
way he's playing especially if he
finishes this season out you got to
stick with Purdy but Tom Brady for one
will not be a Tampa Bay Buccaneer next
year
what do you do if you're the Packers can
you be proactive with Aaron Rodgers and
if so how
no I think that Aaron Rodgers is in a
position with the contract remember
three years 150 million dollars all of
the conversation external noise I think
Aaron Rodgers comes in there peacefully
and says can we come to an amicable
resolution what does that mean like you
say face and I save face but right now
you had a succession plan it's time to
return to that it's time to go to Jordan
oh you think he's done I think he's done
at Green Bay because 13-3
13-3 13-3 home field advantage and now
we're a 500 team not going the right
direction what am I sticking around for
now I am Aaron Rodgers but I'm heavy on
these books let's be real and you need a
team you need to develop these receivers
you need to develop the next quarterback
and I still have enough toothpaste in
the tube where I can go elsewhere and
have success I think this is one of
those where you do me one because I did
you one if Aaron Rodgers comes in
without noise I think it could happen
talking to Marcellus Wiley the podcast
is called more to it Dan Patrick Podcast
Network the former NFL All-Pro defensive
end
we lauded Aaron judge for betting on
himself
right oh my God he bet on himself
Lamar Jackson
bet on himself right
yeah
how does this play out does it play same
as Aaron judges did
there's a big difference in this in
terms of initial reception I think
largely because
Lamar Jackson is being represented by
his mother so already people have a
issue with that they're looking at it
like are you really putting yourself in
the best position do you have the best
counsel do you know what you're doing
basically where judge we didn't start
off in that position now in that
position as well Aaron judge was a guy
that you believed in in terms of talent
production and didn't have issues in
terms of his health and in terms of how
you could perform so we're starting in
two different places already
they always say if you represent
yourself you have a client for a fool
because who is giving you guidance right
who is really showing you the way so now
you get Lamar Jackson and he gets hurt
how does this happen on your contract
year now Lamar Jackson will turn out
like Aaron judge for this reason this
reason alone we saw Dak Prescott get
hurt and in his absence show his value I
think that was shown with Lamar Jackson
if we go down to the last second on the
road to Cincinnati with a backup oh give
me Lamar Jackson we win that game and
you've heard that come out of the locker
room since that game more importantly
Lamar Jackson is Big Business he's a box
office star like this team gets
energized by him so because there's no
failure in Dak Prescott getting hurt and
still got paid and the fact that we're
talking 200 million minimum to a guy
who's making 27 million right now
there's no way he can lose this
situation what did you make a Kirby
smarts
speech before the national title game
oh man are we on air you can hear me no
lie actually on the podcast uh I ranked
the pre-game speeches I've had from my
sixth NFL head coaches and there's none
coming close to what Kirby Smart said I
wish I could repeat it right now but on
the podcast I do point being that was
the hypest most direct Primal engaging
pre-game speech I've ever heard like
there's not going to be another one that
touches that one because he went
straight to the source of why are we
playing football I don't want to always
hear these big terms and phrases and
execution and discipline and commitment
no go knock there
that's it like when you first start
playing football before you knew how to
play before you knew the plays you knew
the scheme you knew to go knock that
Duke like and he just went back to
Channel Zero and that was the best thing
I've ever heard if I were on that team I
would have helped out and chipped in on
that 65 or something win unreal you ever
had a bad pregame speech by a coach
ah ah since I'm doing this for a job uh
I'm sorry coaches but I have to say it
um yeah I did because sometimes they
would go to the emotional Lane too soon
uh sometimes they would say something
that was just too soft and glossy and
we're like dude we're about to go out
there for three hours and hit 300
Pounders and you're sounding like I'm
going to a a play recital or something
you're sounding like we're going to
theater I need something vicious I need
some of that Kirby Smart so Mike Riley
was a great coach for me but too nice so
his pre-game speeches came out too nice
they were like kind of Girl Scout cookie
selling like you know like you're like
all right coach that sounds good he
never got rah-rah he never got riled up
uh Marty Schottenheimer got so emotional
so fast that you were like yeah I'm not
in that place yet Coach I'm still I'm
still just hyped up it's zero zero was
he crying oh hell yeah Marty Marty West
the piece to Great Marty Schottenheimer
he was so passionate he loved football
so much and I'm not lying so much he
would literally just start crying it
could be a Wednesday practice it could
be his pre-game speech he just really
felt it and his lip will start shivering
I was like man I'm not there yet Marty
give me a different lane and then we can
get though
a Wednesday practice and he's getting
that emotional yeah he's into it man
it's crazy but so it runs the gamut then
you get some guys that you know they're
so hyped up and you're like oh my God
this is going down and then you go out
there and lay an egg and you're like
well that speech had nothing to do with
it or we didn't serve up to it uh the 27
point lead by the Chargers
unreal what did Jacksonville do
if you can pinpoint and say that's the
reason why they didn't panic and they
came out and they ended up winning this
game yeah
um a couple things that play one what
Jacksonville did was stay alive
um mentally emotionally on the field
they actually took the best punches and
had their worst efforts and still were
around I remind people of football
because we all get caught up and lost in
the math of football they were down 27-0
and you remember I was that teammate
that walked up to the kicker in Dallas
and said hey bro they're not connected
you're okay well here goes this guy
again when we're down 27-0 I say to
everyone on Jacksonville on my team hey
you know that 27-0 in football is only
four plays four plays away I have to do
this with my kids when we're coaching
we're up big or we're down big I'm like
hey that's only four plays like you
could get caught up in 27. you don't
have to do 27 things better than them
you just got to do four and you're right
back in this thing so they kept their
composure and then you know what what
happens when you get a big lead no
matter what you have to fight against
the temptation of playing it safe
prevent offense prevent defense pre-bits
you from winning those games because you
just take your foot off the gas and next
thing you know the other team starts
inching closer and closer to finally the
momentums on their side and then they
take off
yeah I thought Doug Peterson you know
the whole second half adjustments Peyton
Manning said that's a big myth you don't
have time Tony Dungy said that he made
his second half adjustment and uh he was
going to give his speech and they said
coach you got 30 seconds before the
kickoff and then he said all right
basically let's cut down our mistakes
and then they went out and they ended up
winning the game that we get caught up
in that halftime adjustments there I
think Doug Peterson probably just said
guys
we beat ourselves in the first half we
put them in great position we're only
down 27 to nothing
it could be worse all we have to do is
score stop score and that's what
happened and then all of a sudden now
you put a little pressure on the
Chargers now they go out and go like uh
we got a score here and and it changes
their momentum their Rhythm yeah man it
takes me to one of the the adages I
heard from Bill Belichick that more
games are lost than one in the NFL and
when you digest that you realize no
you're your worst enemy on that football
field right it's not them beating you I
mean we're all big fast stronger we made
it here we're all black belts you're not
out there going to just destroy me or
you know I gotta help you I have to
assist you in that but when I stop
helping you good luck beating me and I
think that's always the halftime
adjustment when you're down especially
that big but also the Chargers in that
moment when you're feeling that pressure
you realize oh I took my foot off the
gas and now that I have to apply it
again it is so difficult to stop start
in the NFL especially emotionally once
you take one gear off downshift it's
hard to go back up to that same level
and once that team is rolling you know
what's going to happen give me the
surprise this weekend
watch for those giants I mean I don't
know what Vegas is saying but those
giants familiar with the Eagles Eagles
long break I think seven and a half
Point underdogs yeah watch for that I'm
not a betting man but uh you know I put
five on it that's something right there
because the Giants are too familiar with
them playing great ball right now you
know Philadelphia had the break so it's
rest and rust and then you got Jalen
Hurst who just got inserted back but is
he in flow one game and what the last
five weeks or so so watch for those
giants they're gonna feel real good and
comfortable playing those Eagles uh it's
a treat the podcast more to it with uh
Marcellus Wiley it's available wherever
you get your podcast and certainly at
danpatrick.com great to talk to you
we'll talk to you next week all right
brother thank you man that's Marcellus
Wiley